Ich stelle mir vor, wie man in so eine mittelalterliche Stadt einreitet und der Pöbel sich um einen Schad und man nur so, das gehört jetzt alles mir. Nee, das Pferd. Einen wunderschönen guten Tag und hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Folge Das Podcast UFO. und bei mir
Stefan Weber,
Stefan Herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Folge, das Podcast UFO und bei mir Stefan Weber, Stefan Tietze, sorry, wohnt in Wild, das ging immer von mir. Ich wünsche dir einen fantastischen Tag. Dankeschön. Hallo da draußen. Bis jetzt. Alles so ein fantastischen Tag. Bis jetzt. Obwohl, dass du es mir gewünscht hast, aber bis jetzt, vielleicht geht es in eine andere Richtung. Geht es dir besser, wenn dir Grüße übermittelt werden? Nein, Grüße lehne ich generell ab. Du lehnst die ab? Ich nehme diesen Gruß nicht ab. Überbringst du Grüße? Ich habe die Melly getroffen, die grüßt sich noch mal ganz herzlich. Ich weise das von mir, wie Wasser von einer Ente, sage ich, das prallt an mir ab. Wie Wasser von einer Lotusblume. Genau, sag Melly bitte, dass ich die Grüße ungeöffnet zurückgebe. Ich habe sie nicht geöffnet, ich möchte damit nichts anfangen, ich möchte damit nichts zu tun haben. Und sollte mir jemand Grüße ausrichten, die ich weiterbringe, dann habe ich in meiner Wohnung eine Kiste, die verlorene Grußkiste, nenne ich sie. Oh nein, so einer bist du. Ja, die kommen nie beim Empfänger an. Ich überbringe sehr gerne Grüße. Nein, nein. Doch, ich freue mich über Grüße und ich bringe gerne Grüße. Grüße bringen heißt für mich auch, damit angeben zu können, dass ich die Person auch kenne, dass ich mit der Person auch zu tun hatte.
Also es ist natürlich, das ist doch mehr, darum geht es doch.
Es geht immer mehr um einen selbst, als um wirklich die Grüße übermitteln.
Natürlich, wenn jetzt irgendwie Kylie Minogue sagt, du grüß doch mal die Hannah von mir, natürlich überbringe ich die dann.
Übrigens, die Kylie hat gesagt.
Die Kylie hat übrigens gesagt.
Ich habe Kylie Minogue noch nie getroffen.
Ganz liebe Grüße.
Ich glaube, du lügst, Florian.
Was, nein, ich habe die letzte Spam.
Ich habe Kylie-Milog noch nie getroffen. Ganz liebe Grüße. Ich glaube, du lügst, Flo und die. Was? Nein, ich habe die letztens beim Rewe getroffen. Arbeitet sie da? Also als Aushilfe halt manchmal, wenn sie gerade nicht irgendwo auftritt. Und dann hat die gesagt, Anna, Flo und die, Mensch, du, ich habe letztens noch an die Hanna, ja, ich glaube, du lügst. Du, ich habe an die Hannah gedacht letztens, weil ich habe nämlich die Folge gesehen von Friends, die wir damals zusammen geguckt haben bei ihr in der Wohnung, als ich beim Umzug geholfen habe. Ich glaube, du lügst. Und dann habe ich gesagt, na klar, Kylie, richtig Hanna aus und jetzt rieche ich sie aus. So, Flotin, ich gucke mir das jetzt schon ein paar Monate mit an, diese Lügerei und jetzt kommst du mal bitte mit, komm mal kurz mit. Ich habe nämlich die Sekretchen besorgt, so. Was ist das denn heiß? Das musst du dir mal kurz ans Ohrläppchen stecken und das musst du dir irgendwo auf die Brust kleben. Ich habe nichts zu verbergen. Und jetzt erzählst du noch mal von A bis Z, wie Kylie Minogue mir die Grüße übermittelt hat. Ich war gestern einkaufen. Im welchem Supermarkt warst du einkaufen? Vorher muss ich ein paar Fragen stellen, übrigens. Welche Haarfarbe hast du? Kann ich kurz nachgucken? Haben sie einen Spiegel? Brünett? Hast du Haustiere? Nein. Merkwürdiger Ausschlag hier, okay. Gut, jetzt habe ich es eigentlich... Er geht nach links. Normalerweise oben und unten, aber er geht nach links. Er geht nach links. Selbst das Gerät guckt mich mit diesem Emoji an, mit diesem skeptischen Emoji. Echtzeit machen mich diese Fragen schon nervös. Ja, das hat ja keinen Grund, dass du nervös bist. So, jetzt, also Kylie Minogue. Also, ich war gestern einkaufen bei Penny. Okay, das ist die Wahrheit. Und da habe ich eine berühmte Sängerin getroffen. Hier steht, er glaubt nur. Hier steht sogar nicht nur auf Fall. Was ist das für ein Gerät? Das ist ein neuer Lügendetektor. Da steht nicht nur drauf, ob du lügst oder nicht, wie so ein Seismograph. Nein, der zeigt mir auch das Erdbeben an, das ist aber auch so ein Feature, das brauche ich nicht unbedingt, hier, aber nett, aber es zeigt mir vor allem deine Gedanken, was du wirklich erlebt hast, und da steht, du glaubst nur, dass das Kylie Minogue war, die sah so aus wie Kylie Minogue. Ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass es Kylie Minogue war. Genau. Weil du ein miserables Gedächtnis hast.
Du weisst nicht mehr, wie Kylie Minogue aussieht.
So, und die hat gesagt, richte doch Hannah liebe schöne Grüsse aus.
Wir haben damals eine Folge Friends geguckt, als ich beim Umzug geholfen habe. Hat sie gesagt, ob das stimmt, weiß ich nicht, das hat sie mir so gesagt. Ja, um diese Lüge geht es jetzt nicht. Ob sie lügt, kann ich ja nicht, das schlägt ja nicht aus, wenn sie mich angelogen hat. Doch, das ist der neue Lügemark 3000. Wenn Kylie Minogue mir rotzfrech ins Gesicht gelogen hat, dass sich die Balken biegen, das kann doch der nicht sehen. Gut, du sagst die Wahrheit, vielen Dank. Richte dir auch schöne Grüße aus. Alles klar, hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Unsere Beziehung macht sehr viel Spaß. Mir geht es auch gut, wenn Leute mir Grüße übermitteln. Ja, nee, aber wie viele Grüße hast du aktuell pending gerade? Also wie viele hast du gerade im Köcher? Null. Null? Letzte Woche hatte ich einen im Köcher, habe ich dir übermittelt. Aber sonst habe ich keine Grüße, gerade pending. Okay, gut, alles klar. Bin ich auch immer froh, wenn ich Grüße pending habe, immer nervös. Einen Gruß möchte ich noch raushauen, und zwar an Luca für das fantastische Intro. Wow. Vielen, vielen Dank, das hat uns sehr gefallen, noch mal ein kleiner Flashback in eine alte, in eine vergangene Zeit, die vielleicht besser war. Eine alte Folge, an die wir uns nicht mehr erinnern können. Ich glaube, wir hatten eine sehr lange Pferdephase mal, wo wir sehr große Fans von Pferden waren. Unschön, unschön. Ich bin ja tatsächlich viel auf, und ich gebe es zu, und es ist ein Abgrund der Aufmerksamkeitsspanne, Instagram Reels, Instagram, also so Stories, keine Stories, aber so wie TikTok auf Instagram im Grunde, es ist im Grunde TikTok, aber auf Instagram, im Grunde TikTok, aber ich habe halt die TikTok-App halt nicht. Wir alle leben in diesem Jahrzehnt. Über Instagram. Also ich habe ein Smartphone, das ist im Grunde, naja, stellst du dir vor wie ein Taschenrechner, der Zugang zum Internet.
Wo man mehr lustige Sachen machen kann als Esel eingeben, der mehr Knöpfer hat, ja, wenn du da Bubz eingibst, dann ist es nochmal eine ganz andere Dimension, okay? Und es kriegen auch mehr mit. Es kriegen auch mehr mit, weil es gibt da Seiten. Gib nicht Bub sein.
Also das ist schon manchmal...
Das ist irre, was man findet, wirklich. Aber anderes Thema. Und da bin ich auf Instagram, TikTok unterwegs. Und auch da hast du ja immer nur die Wahl, nächstes Video, nächstes Video, nächstes Video. Du hast eigentlich nur die Wahl, wie lange gucke ich mir das Video an. Und der Algorithmus checkt dann, ah, alles, was mit Katzen zu tun hat, schaust du dir 80% des TikToks an, also mehr Katzen. Und irgendwann, du scrollst da einfach nur durch und merkst plötzlich, aha, anscheinend bin ich Fan von Billie Eilish. Also, die kommt ständig und dann, das ist gar kein bewusstes Fan-Tum. Nee, ist so ein Self-Fulfilling Prophecy auch, weil du wirst ja dann zum Fan von Billie Eilish. Genau, es ist aber so, aha, ich habe durch diesen Algorithmus gerade jetzt erfahren, dass ich ein riesen Billie Eilish-Fan bin, weil jedes zweite Video ist Billie Eilish. Und ich habe nichts gegen sie, aber ich würde mich nicht als Fan bezeichnen, aber anscheinend hat dieses Programm für mich jetzt wissenschaftlich rausgefunden, Zeig mal dein Shirt, zeig mal dein... Naja, das ist ... Warum ... Es ist ein Billie-Eilish-Shirt. Ja, weil ich das halt zugeschickt ... Ich habe halt so viel Werbung bekommen und dann habe ich halt auf irgendwas draufgetippt, aus Versehen. Aus Versehen und angezogen und es passt. Es war die richtige Grösse, denn diese Algorithmen wissen ja alles überein heutzutage, das wundert mich nicht. Aber interessant eigentlich, dass man sich so seine Interessen gar nicht selber aussuchen muss, sondern einfach so sein Gehirn anschließt an diese Algorithmusmaschine und die da einfach mal durchrührt mit so einem Quirrel und einfach mal so durchmischt dein Gehirn und sagt am Ende, aha, wie so ein Sieb. Die sieben so dein Gehirn raus und unten fällt raus, ja, du liebst anscheinend diese Kitesurfer, die über Inseln drüber springen, kleine Inseln, und Männer, das ist bei mir nämlich ein bisschen so, ich habe so viele, und das kommt glaube ich aus meiner Fitness-Self-Improving-Phase, ich habe so viele oberkörperfreie Männer, wenn ich unten auf die Lupe klicke bei Instagram, wenn man sucht, wenn man neue Profile sucht oder so, da hat man ja ganz viele Vorschläge.
Und dieser Algorithmus ist bei mir abgedriftet. Auch lustigerweise, und ich glaube auch, dass Algorithmen manchmal falsch liegen in der Hinsicht, dass man, wenn man mal nach etwas sucht,
denken diese Algorithmen ja, okay, jetzt geben wir ihm alles davon. Also wenn man zum Beispiel mal, keine Ahnung, sich mal ein Schachvideo anguckt und dann sagt YouTube ja auch hier, hier ist a whole new world, viel Spaß mit 80 Millionen Stunden Schachcontent und die überwerfen dich ja damit. Das ist ja nicht zwangsläufig, also wenn man sich ein Video anguckt, da heißt es nicht zwangsläufig, dass man ja gerade irgendwie in diesem Rabbit Hole ist. Und dann kommt man aber rein. Also die haben ja dann doch recht. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das nicht an einem selber liegt. Ja, vor allem das Problem an dem Algorithmus ist ja auch, dass der nicht merkt, ob dir das Video gefällt oder nicht. Der sieht nur, ob du es anschaust oder nicht. Und mein Problem zum Beispiel ist, dass ich momentan ziemlich tief bin in so einer Inspirational-Video-Ecke. Also so, hey, du kannst es schaffen, nur du stehst dir selber im Weg. Weil, immer wenn mir das in der Timeline ist, denke ich, es wird am Ende noch komödiantisch gebrochen. Weil es gibt ja oft so Videos, die so anfangen mit, du kannst alles schaffen und am Ende kommt die Pointe als Gag irgendwas, dass noch mal sowas, also das gebrochen wird. Das ist eine gängige Art von Video. Wie viele Videos und wie lange schaust du schon diese Inspirational-Videos ohne Pointe? Nein, aber wenn du, keine Ahnung, halt so auf Nein-Gag unterwegs bist oder halt so Comedy-Seiten, dann kriegst du immer wieder so die dann irgendwie, so es gibt nur drei Dinge stehen in deinem Leben, du selbst, bla bla bla und dann halt als dritter irgendein Pointe-Gag, halt irgendwas Lustiges zum Abroffeln so. Und dann, das gucke ich mir gerne an, klatsche in die Hände und freue mich aufs nächste Video.
Und das Problem ist ja, dass diese Videos leben
vom Brechen der Erwartungen, klassischer
L-Form, da sind wir schon wieder. Da sind wir schon wieder.
Aber was ist das Problem, wenn du halt
ein L erwartest, aber es ist ein kleines L?
Das ist mehr so ein
I-Video, genau.
Das bleibt auf derselben
Linie. Und du kannst ja dann nicht sagen
dem Algorithmus, das mochte ich nicht.
Das hat mir gefeuert.
Doch, es gibt einen Button, der genau das kann. Aber jetzt willst du nicht, du kannst auf nicht gefällt mir klicken. Es gibt kein nicht gefällt mir, es gibt nur Like oder es gibt kein Daumen runter. Dann gibt es einen Daumen runter. Nein, auf Instagram gibt es einen Daumen runter. Ach, aber YouTube. Nee, nee, ich bin, also, du bist in der ...
Es ist sowas wie TikTok, also, naja, wie soll ich das erklären?
Also, du bist in der App. Es ist sowas wie TikTok. Also, nein, wie soll ich dir das erklären? Also, TikTok ist eine andere App. Du bist in der Motivationssprecherding bei Instagram gefangen. Genau, es ist Instagram, aber es ist jetzt so eine Art von TikTok. Es ist nicht, dass du dir nur die Bilder anguckst, sondern es sind kurze Videos. Denk an Wein, wie Wein früher war. Think Wein, but longer. Genau, aber mehr so wie TikTok, aber auf Instagram. Das haben wir schon verstanden. Ich frage mich jetzt gerade nur, da machen Leute so Motivationsbetöne. Ja, total. Okay, und das guckst du dann da? Ich gucke es an und dann von einem ironischen, ja, zynischen Gag-Roffel-Ansatz trifft dich langsam ab in, nee, ich muss
wirklich mal mein Leben überdenken.
Also vielleicht
stehe ich mir wirklich nur selber im Weg.
Ja, ich glaube, du stehst dir selber, also
nimm dir das nicht so sehr zu Herzen, diese Videos, bitte.
Ja, aber die haben halt schon immer oft so Sonnenuntergänge
und so, weil die
die wissen halt, was sich rühren.
Weil da heißt es halt, ja, du kannst ein Haus kaufen, aber kein Zuhause kaufen. Und dann denke ich mir, ja, das stimmt. Also was heißt, was macht einen eigentlich wirklich so? Aber ganz kurz, macht uns Instagram slash TikTok langsam unlustiger? Ich glaube, man muss es richtig nutzen. Ich will nicht, dass Instagram nicht bricht. Ich glaube, es ist ein Drall. Ich glaube, du musst aktiv dagegen ankämpfen. Ein Drall? Ja, es ist wie ein Drall. Das ist wie wenn du so einen Einkaufswagen hast, der immer nach links drallt. Jeder kennt es. Und du musst aktiv dagegen arbeiten, sonst würdest du immer schön, weil die sind ja nicht dumm, links sind immer die Süssigkeiten, rechts ist das Gemüse. Natürlich stellen die alle ihre Wegen so ein, dass die nach links drallen, weil die genau wissen, dass sie unauffallsam gegen eine Süssersegerade geknallen. Jetzt haue ich mir halt nochmal schön die Kinderriegel rein und halt nicht das Gemüse, weil Gemüse verdienen die weniger Geld. Okay, alles klar. Kann sein. Hast du da auch viele, bist du auch in so einer Verschwörungsvideo-Ecke gelandet oder das noch nicht? Nein, das ist ja keine Verschwörung, das ist ja echt. Ja, genau, das ist genau das, was Verschwörungsvierdiker sagen würden. Und so ist es, glaube ich, bei Instagram auch oder Social Media, dass die sich aktiv in so eine Satire, Weltverbesserungs, moralische Ecke drallen wollen. Aber du musst aktiv dagegen arbeiten und dann kommst du da vielleicht auch raus. Mit Billie Eilish und Motivations, ist es nicht so weit auseinander. Das ist das Problem. Und dann gibt es Motivationsvideos mit Billie Eilish. Dann ist Billie Eilish, die dir erzählt, ich habe auch mal angefangen wie so ein mieser Wurm wie du und jetzt bin ich Billie Eilish. Ja, das stimmt halt auch. Du bist Billie Eilish und ich bin ein mieser Wurm. Das ist halt korrekt. Ich bin ein mieser, mieser Wurm. Und naja, also wie gesagt, vielleicht ändere ich Dinge in meinem Leben, vielleicht packe ich mich nochmal bei den Schultern. Hörnern? Hast du denn? Zieh mich auf dem Sumpf meines Privatlebens heraus, weil es stimmt schon, du kannst wirklich kein Zuhause kaufen. Du kannst, klar, wenn du genug Geld hast, kannst du dein Haus kaufen. Aber es ist dann kein Zuhause. Nicht notwendigerweise. Kannst du mal einen Link schicken zu diesen? Klar, ich habe da ganz viele gesammelt auch, weil ich dachte, da kommt noch ein Gag und dann speichere ich die schon mal ab. Was es halt heißt, ist, dass du dir für Geld Dinge kaufen kannst. Aber du kannst das Gefühl, kannst du dir nicht kaufen. Genau, du kannst sozusagen nicht das Glück, dass du dir von den Dingen versprichst, notwendigerweise kaufen. Weißt du, wie ich es am liebsten aufbereitet hätte, damit ich es richtig glaube? So einen Sonnenuntergang oder so einen Strand, Palmstrand. Du kannst dir einen Urlaub kaufen, aber keine Erinnerung. So. Ja, du hast schon recht. Ist es immer dieser Mechanismus mit dem Kaufen-Satz? Ja. Okay. Ja, es ist immer das Gleiche. Ach so. Du kannst dir kein Macbook kaufen, weil du zu wenig Geld hast. Mach ich das richtig? Nicht ganz. Du kannst dir ein Macbook kaufen, aber keine Kreativität. So was vielleicht.
Du kannst dir ein... Es richtet sich vor allem an gut verdienende Menschen. Ja, es sind oft teure Sachen. Du kannst den Haus kaufen, aber kein zu Hause. Nein, ich kann mir kein Haus kaufen. Du kannst dir ein Die müssen auch diese ganzen Motivational Influencer müssen auch ganz schön hart arbeiten, oder? Du kannst dir Strauss Tomaten kaufen, aber kein ne du kannst dir Freunde kaufen, aber kein Glück, aber du kannst dir auch keine Freunde kaufen. Lass uns noch mal das mit Heimat und Haus machen mit einer anderen Farbe. Wir gehen noch mal zurück. Lass uns das vielleicht mit so einem verträumten Wald oder sowas machen. Sowas in der Richtung. Aber nee, also von daher, mal gucken. Also ich habe auch Tickets für Billie Eilish 2023. Du kannst dir Tickets zum Billie Eilish-Konzert kaufen, aber nicht,
aber keine Gänsehaut.
Oh, okay.
Gefällt mir, gefällt mir, ja.
Du kannst dir Schuhe kaufen,
aber
nicht Billie Eilish-Schuhe.
Nee, Achtung,
jetzt pass mal auf, ich hab was.
Du kannst dir ein Auto kaufen,
aber nicht das, wo du dann damit hinfahren willst. Aber keine Freunde, mit denen du in Urlaub fährst. So? Ja. Ja, aber du musst dir auch kaufen. Du kannst dir einen Caravan kaufen, aber keine Begleitung. Einen Caravan? Ja, wie sagt man das so? Caravan. Du kannst dir einen Caravan kaufen, der ganze Raum nickt. Ja, stimmt. Könnte ich machen. Ich will lieber machen. Ich meine, du kannst dir einen Katamaran kaufen, aber nicht den Wind. Nein, das ist alles... Naja, ich weiß nicht genau, was ein Katamaran... Naja, egal. auf jeden Fall sind das meine neuen Hobbys. Aber das ist auch lustigerweise beim Schreiben der Serie How to Sell Drugs, da haben wir ja leider Gottes diese Voice-Over-Ebene, wo Moritz immer wahnsinnig clevere Sachen sagt. Und was man als Autor häufig vergisst, ist, dass man diese Sachen sich selber ausdenken muss. Man denkt so, ja, dann sagt die Moritz was Cleveres.
Ja genau, du hast im Textschild clever, clever, clever, clever.
Clever Talk, Clever Talk. Sollen wir das so drehen? Ah, fuck. Ach nee, gib da mal, die Schildkröte kann sich in den Panzer einziehen, aber ist dafür langsam. Du kannst dir nicht, du kannst dir eine Schildkröte kaufen und dann sitzen Philipp und ich dann immer noch. Das ist immer die langweigigste Arbeit, weil du willst ja coole, quotable lines schreiben.
Ja. Das ist wirklich, das ist eine grosse Herausforderung. Aber macht das Spaß. Schwierig. Schwierig. Von daher, ich glaube, so ohne Ironie, so Selbsthilfe-Sachen zu schreiben, ist auch nicht zu unterschätzen als Arbeit. Aber ist es nicht auch so wie Kinderbuchautoren, weil Kinderbücher werden ja nicht von Kindern geschrieben, so ist es nicht dann auch, dass solche Inspirationsbücher von total deprimierten, zynischen Arschlöchern geschrieben werden, die sich das halt so aus den Fingern saugen?
Ja.
Vielleicht musste das sogar sein, damit du das schreiben kannst.
Ich stelle mir die so vor wie den Protagonisten in Her, Tolkien Phoenix in Her.
Ja, ja.
Tolkien Phoenix?
Nee.
Ist es Tolkien Phoenix?
Doch, ja. Jung halt. Guter Film. Aber es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr Und dann, wenn man das in fünf Jahren anguckt, ist es schwierig. Zum Beispiel, also ich meine, ich mache mir halt ein bisschen Sorgen um die Avatar-Reihe von James Cameron, weil Avatar 1 war ein Riesenerfolg, kam aber halt auch raus 2011 oder was. Und seitdem arbeitet er ja an den zweiten und dritten Teil. Das steht ja seit IMDB, auf IMDB steht es schon seit der erste Teil veröffentlicht wurde, steht da Work in Progress zweiter, dritter Teil. und ich hoffe, also ich habe echt Angst davor, dass der da irgendwie so, irgendwie halt so Harlem Shake Gags einbaut oder so, die halt damals, 2013, halt lustig waren. Und wenn der Film jetzt rauskommt, das ist ja auch im ersten Teil, was den Film ja so brädiant gemacht hat, waren diese vielen zeitgemässen popkulturellen Referenzen. Genau, ja. Also davon hat Avatar ja gelebt. Im Grunde schon. Von den ganzen Flashmops. Diese ganzen Oops, I did it again, Choreo-Nummern, wie die da auf Pandora unterwegs waren, fand ich halt schon cool. Ja, auch dieser Flashmop, wir nehmen kurz euren Planeten ein und dann sind wir weg. Ja, genau, so wie ein Flashmop. Ich war ja schon, also von daher, da hast du schon recht, es war eine berechtigte Angst. Weil das ist halt klar, das war halt damals lustig, als James Cameron sich das 2013 ausgedacht hat. Voll, voll. Gangnam Style, Referenz irgendwie, Crazy Frog und so. Der Soundtrack auch, dieser Pop-Soundtrack war auch, der hat ja auch gepasst. Justin Bieber kann es so heute halt nicht mehr. Poker, Papa, Poker, Face, Papa, Poker, Face. Das war ja ... Und da habe ich jetzt auch Angst, das stimmt schon. Und vor allem halt, durch die Pandemie wird das auch noch mal verschoben. Und wenn dann 2024 Avatar 2 rauskommt und du checkst halt überhaupt nichts mehr ... Dann wurden inzwischen durch so Masken draufretuschiert, aber dann, weil dann die Pandemie vorbei ist, wieder wegretuschiert und dann waren die Münder so strange, weil man auch, weil man die CDs, die CD-Roms nicht mehr benutzen konnte mit dem alten Entwurf, weil das schon, die sind schon kaputt, weil CDs halten ja nur 20 Jahre. Und dann wollten die eigentlich erst mal neue Gags machen mit den aktuellen Memes, dann irgendwie ha ha ha Armin Laschet oder was. Und das ist dann aber auch wieder verschoben worden durch die Pandemie und dann halt wieder alles anders. Das ist so das, glaube ich, wo ich mir momentan am meisten Sorgen mache, dass die völlig am Ziel vorbeischießen einfach. Und das lässt mich nicht schlafen manchmal. Ja, ich mache mir auch große Sorgen um James Cameron, weil er kann sich einen Film kaufen, aber nicht
das Genie.
Weil da ist zu viel Zeit
zwischen Teil 1 und 2. Also ich glaube,
normalerweise ist ja, also
das ist meine These, ich glaube,
statistisch vergeht mehr Zeit
zwischen 2 und 3 als zwischen
1 und 2.
Weil wenn 1 erfolgreich ist, kommt sofort 2
und dann vielleicht noch mal
irgendwann drei wenn man dann okay ich glaube nicht ich glaube nach einem erfolgreichen teil
eins werden sofort zwei und drei auflage geben ja okay oder so aber dass der 2011 rauskommt und
dann 2024 teil zwei die schauspieler sind alle uralt die schauspieler haben eine tertur im
gesicht oder so ich dachte das ist mehr so, man zählt die Welt nochmal, aber halt jetzt eine andere Geschichte. Ja, muss vielleicht sein. Muss vielleicht sein. Willst du die alle nochmal haben? Sergeant und Officer General. Dann hier die Navi-Frau mit dann diese Eidexen. Das ist schon eines meiner Lieblingsuniversen und ich freue mich da auch gerne wieder zurückzukehren. Aber wie gesagt, es wird schwierig.
Und ich finde das total blöd, dieses zynische Fertiggemache von Avatar.
Ich habe den Film dann mal so toll gefunden.
Gut, ich war noch klein.
Irgendwann denkt man ja die Story schon arg eins zu eins.
Aber gut.
Naja, ist halt visuell 3D, aber auf der anderen Seite. Aber merkwürdig, weil der war ja der erfolgreichste Film der Welt, der am meisten Geld eingespielt hat, bis er überholt wurde von Avengers Endgame. Wo ja auch die Navi am Ende aufgetreten sind, aus Doctor Strange Stingcom und dann ist es der Rieden-Crossover. Wir brauchen Snoopy und die Navi am Ende aufgetreten sind. Auch eine kleine Rolle halten. Aus Doctor Strange Stinkum. Und dann ist es der Rieden-Crossover. Wir brauchen Snoopy und die Navi. Und die Navi. Und den Bärenmarke-Bär. Mach ein Portal auch für den Bärenmarke-Bär. Und die Ewoks und dann kämpfen die Ewoks gegen, aber das ist der Plot-Twist, Plot-Twist, kämpfen die Navi gegen die Ewoks. Obwohl die eigentlich für die gleiche Sache kämpfen und die gleiche Rolle innerhalb ihrer Universen erfüllen, kämpfen sie gegeneinander. Man weiß nicht genau, für wen man ist. Das ist genial. Auch da gerne bitte die Crossover-Geschichten ganz kurz, bitte ganz kurz. Bitte, aber reißt euch zusammen. Wirklich in Limerick-Form, wirklich. Ihr habt doch keinen Mörg auf Hausaufgaben, haben wir doch gemerkt. Ein Vierzeiler, ein Vierzeiler mehr nicht. Aber das wurde ja dann übernommen von Avengers Endgame. Aber Avengers Endgame ist doch der letzte Teil der Serie. Und hat man auch Inflation und so einberechnet? Glaube ich nämlich nicht. Ah nee, doch. Hat man sich verrechnet, glaube ich. Das kann gut sein, dass man sich verrechnet hat. Wie bei dem höchsten Gebäude der Welt hat man sich auch lange verrechnet. War lange der Kölner Dom.chnet. Und mittlerweile ist es Burj Khalifa. Aber wie kann es sein, dass Endgame der erfolgreichste Teil ist, wenn es der letzte Teil ist? Dann müssen ja mehr Leute den letzten Teil gesehen haben als den Teil davor. Oder damit er mehr Geld einnimmt. Das Ding ist ja, da kam ja alle, das hat ja alle in die Kinos getrieben. Die Fans von The Hulk, die Fans von The Spider-Man, die Fans von The Doctor Strange, so, The Snoopy Fans, dann die Fans von The Black Panther, Power Rangers, The Power Rangers, so, der Teil hat ja alle verbunden. Heißt nicht nur die The Tor-Fans gehen dann in ihren Filmen rein, die gehen auch in Endgame rein, wobei nicht alle sich auf das Tor einigen können, aber alle können sich auf den Film einigen, wo alle drin vorkommen. Das kann sein? Aber es muss doch dann rein mathematisch in Avengers Endgame Leute gesessen haben, die nicht verstanden haben, was los ist. Was Super Mario jetzt da macht. Weil sonst hätte ja irgendein anderer Film davor mehr eingenommen, wenn alle den davor gesehen hätten. Bestes Beispiel, ich. Du hast nur Endgame gesehen und hast nichts verstanden. Doch, ich habe nämlich vorher, denn das kann man ja auch, auf Blu-Ray slash streamen die Sachen nachgeholt. Ach, das zählt dann nicht zum Geld eingenommen. Das weiß ich nicht. Nee, geht's bei diesem Geld eingenommen nicht am ersten Wochenende? Du meinst, dass du so Home Office, Box Office und Home Cinema, Home Kino, nicht mit Zählen. Es gibt die beiden Sachen. Ja. Box Office und Home Box Office. HBO. Was ist der nächste Film, der noch mehr Geld einnimmt? Also wir hatten jetzt einmal, es ist beides war Science Fiction, Avatar. Können wir nicht mal jetzt anhand dieser erfolgreichen Filme, kannst du mal eine Liste aufmachen mit den erfolgreichen Filmen aller Zeiten und wir machen daraus jetzt den nächsten krassen Hit. Weil eigentlich, es müsste ja eine logische Reihenfolge sein, oder? Ja. Es muss ja irgendwie weitergehen. Avatar auf eins. Oh, Avatar ist immer noch auf eins. Das ist ja eben nicht mehr verrechnet. Ich sag doch. Also, das ist das erfolgreichste, die erfolgreichsten Filme weltweit nach Einspielergebnis.
Mein Platz Nummer eins, Avatar, Aufbruch nach Pandora, dann Avengers Endgame auf Platz zwei, Titanic auf drei, Star Wars, das Erwachen der Macht auf vier. Ja, aber guck mal, das ergibt Sinn, The Force Awakens war der erste Teil. Der erste der neuen. Und das ergibt total Sinn, dass der erste Teil am meisten eingespielt hat, weil danach ja immer weniger ins Kino gehen, notenigerweise, aber nicht sich jemand den zweiten anschaut und den ersten gesehen haben. Also da ergibt es total Sinn. Und dann fünf ist schon Infinity War. Aber also wie gesagt, wir haben Titanic, Endgame, Avatar sind die besten drei. Also wir haben Schiff. Titanic passt nicht rein, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Titanic verstehe ich nicht. Was kommt als nächstes, weil wir haben ja irgendwie die Form von Reise in allen drei, das ist Infinity War nicht unbedingt. Naja, in Endgame. Naja, doch, da wird auch viel gereist. Also Krieg ist ausser in Titanic in allen Filmen omnipräsent. Bei Titanic kein Krieg. Romantik ist auch in allen Filmen in Endgame nicht drin. Tatsächlich haben die keine, das schließt sich irgendwie so aus, wie dieses Dreieck, was man wählen kann. Beauty, Creativity und es gibt so ein Dreieck, wo man sich nur, man kann sich nur zwei Sachen wählen. Und das ist ein bisschen so wie bei diesen Dreifeln. Reich, schön, schlau oder was? Ja, reich, schön, schlau. Du musst wissen, welches von den Dreien will ich nicht. Choose two. Okay. Was willst du nehmen? Ja, natürlich reich und schlau. Schönheit kann man sich kaufen, aber keine Liebe. Ja, du hängst so viel bei Instagram rum. Aber es ist alles ausser Titanic halt so Science-Fiction-Zeug.
Titanic fällt auch ein bisschen die Rechnung kaputt.
Titanic ist schwierig.
Ich glaube, der nächste Teil wird wieder ...
Science-Fiction ist schon stark überrepräsentiert.
Aber angenommen, wir machen aus Titanic ein Raumschiff.
Ein Raumschiff, und zwar ...
Fährt gegen Asteroiden.
Ist Titanic nicht einfach nur quasi ein Aufbruch, ist es nicht interstellarartig, ein Aufbruch von der Erde irgendwo hin.
Alles hat so einen Pioniercharakter, so ein großes Schiff gab es noch nie und so, grosses Raumschiff.
Und zwar, wir machen nämlich Avatar 2, ist nämlich quasi ein Titanic-artiges Schiff, auf der eine Romanze stattfindet, wirklich der Aufbruch nach Pandora. Ein Riesenraumschiff, das heißt Britannic, fliegt nach Pandora auf der Reise. Aber warte mal, kann es nicht ein U-Boot sein? Dass man sagt, bei Titanic war das Schiff oben und dann untergegangen, und wir drehen es um, das U-Boot, und geht dann auf.
Im Weltall?
Naja, es kann ja auch ein Wasserplanet sein, der komplett aus Wasser besteht. Und niemand weiß, was im Inneren ist. Gut. Und die fliegen mit einer Rakete, erst fliegen sie durchs All und dann schlagen sie, machen sie ein Hecht quasi, Hemanöver, in den Wasserplaneten und tauchen dann tief. Dann hast du noch so das Boot, Atmosphäre drin vielleicht ein bisschen. Wie landet man auf dem Wasserplaneten? Hecht, Hecht, reinhechten. Weil du kannst ja quasi, verstehst du, auf der Erde kannst du ja nicht, du kannst ja nicht in die Erde fliegen, weißt du? Du kannst aber in den Wasserplaneten fliegen. Ja. Ist es nicht total geil? Ich weiß. Ja, verstehst du nicht, was ich meine? Auf der Erde musst du dich aufwendig drehen und landen. Ja. Du kannst aber senkrecht in die Innenwasserplaneten reinfliegen. Der ist ein Hecht. Oder was meinst du jetzt? Ich glaube, ich meine ein Hecht. Ich verstehe nicht genau, was du mit Hecht meinst.
Na halt reinhechten, geht's Wasser.
Du wirst ja gegen den Planeten dötzen.
Du willst ja Wasser.
Aber du willst so titschen, oder was?
Du willst titschen.
Wenn jeder Planet ist, Leute, also natürlich eine linke Faust.
Er ballt seine linke Faust, er hebt sie.
Und das Raumschiff fliegt geradeaus drauf zu.
Flache Hand fliegt auf die Faust. Geradeaus drauf zu und fliegt und taucht im 90-Grad-Winkel rein. Nimmst du dann den Planeten nicht anders wahr? Weil der ja nicht mehr ... Verstehst du, du bist ja nicht mehr ... Du nimmst ihn ja als Wand wahr mehr, weil du ja reinfliegst. Ach so. Auf der Erde musst du landen. Ja, ja, ja. Stimmt, du hast dann von Anfang an die falsche Ausrichtung sozusagen. Du denkst, der Planet ist vor dir, nicht unter dir.
Ja, das meine ich. Hast du nicht ein anderes Verhältnis und sinkt man den nicht runter aus dem Planeten wieder raus?
Du meinst, daran scheitert letzten Endes die Mission, weil die Astronauten immer sich so gegen den Planeten festhalten, als würden sie an der Klippe hängen.
Die rutschen runter, das war eine These. Weil es halt falsch verstanden haben. Das stimmt schon, ja. Ich glaube, du hast noch nicht ganz verstanden. Weil die Erde, da muss man sich ja aufwendig drehen und dann landest du auf der Erde und du hast eine weite Fläche vor dir. Ja, und dann stehst du raus mit den Füßen auf der Erde. Und die ist unter dir plötzlich. Ja. Aber das Verhältnis ist ja ein anderes, wenn du in den Planeten reinfliegst. Ich verstehe schon, dann ist der Planet vor dir. Der ist halt einfach im Weg. Als würdest du an der Wand hängen. Oh, aber jetzt die Frage, sind Wasserplaneten immer auch Gesteinsplaneten? Oder kann man quasi einfach wie so eine Bubble durchbraten? Das ist ja genau das, das versuchen die genau zu beantworten. Das ist die Frage, die am Anfang des Films steht. Also Schwarzbild, tönende Musik, Synthi-Sounds mit Textwall. Erstmal. Long in the time in the galaxy, far forward. Ist jeder Wasserplanet, grosse Schrift, Riesenschrift, jeder Buchstabe ist raumfüllend, raumfüllend, nicht bildschirmfüllend. Wir haben Bildschirme an jeder Seite.
Also reden wir schon auch von 4D, klar. Ja, ja, wir haben auf der linken Seite des Kinos, rechter Seite des Kinos Leinwände, oben Leinwand, alles voller Leinwand. Der Langnesemann selbst muss in Form eines Krisenbuchstabens, kommt rein. Wir haben jeder Buchstabe einzeln eingeblendet, ist jeder Wasserplanet auch ein Gesteinsplanet und ein 16 Fragezeichen. Währenddessen röhrt die Musik auf. Das Publikum macht die Augen zu. Einzige Chance, um sich zu retten, ist alle, kneifen die Augen zu. Manche halten sich zusätzlich noch die Hand vor die Augen, weil das Licht durch die Augen, die da durchgeht. Eine Mutter schreit, ich habe ein Kind mitgebracht. Und dann das Orchester röhrt noch mal auf zu einem sechzehn schlägigen Stakkato, sechzehn stündigen, zu den sechzehn Fragezeichen, bam bam bam bam bam bam bam, stille. Wir sehen durch das Dunkel ein Raumschiff. Die Britannic. Keinen Ton. Huch, er wird runtergedreht. Wir haben keinen Ton. Aber steht drauf, MS Britannic. Ja, aber Achtung, das Raumschiff ist von Anfang an falsch rum. So, da wollte ich mit dir drüber reden. Weil wir als Zuschauer wissen, die Trottel sind falsch rum abgehoben, die wissen es aber noch nicht. Und ein Sticker von Billie Eilish auf dem Rumpf. Das heißt, oder ist er auf der Leinwand? Der bewegt sich gar nicht. Nee, das stimmt. Moment mal, ist das Teil des Films? Kann niemand, Entschuldigung, Eilish abknibbeln. Es gibt den Siniastenruf Eilisch.
Ja, den gibt es bis dato schon.
Eilisch, Eilig, Eilisch.
Und jemand eilt zur Leinwand, um abzuknibbeln.
Ich kriege ihn nicht ab, ich kriege ihn nicht ab.
So, wir schneiden ins Raumschiff, auch da Bild auf dem Kopf.
Alle Personen auf dem Kopf, weil die ja falsch rum sind. Aber die merken das nicht, nur der Zuschauer weiß das. Der Zuschauer denkt, er ist falsch. Die ersten versuchen sich in ihren Kinositzen umzudrehen, weil es so unendlich nervig ist, dass das Bild immer falsch rum ist, aber James Cameron hat sich dabei was gedacht, denn er möchte, darum geht es ja in dem Film, es geht um Perspektiven. Es geht um James Cameron. So heißt der Film auch. Perspektiven. So heißt der Film. Perspektiven und Hoffnung. Und so die reden über normales Zeug, der Hyperantrieb hat die richtige Temperatur, gut, lass uns Eis essen.
Und was ist, nee, dann sagt aber der junge Praktikant auf der Brücke, der heute mal, genau, jeder Praktikant macht einen Tag in jedem Bereich des Raumschiffs.
Einmal Maschinenraum, einmal Kantine, einmal Brücke. Heute ist er auf der Brücke.
Heute muss er das Schiff fliegen.
Ja, so, weil das ist eigentlich Autopilot, aber die sagen, setz dich mal an den Controller. Die haben so einen Controller. Die haben so einen USB-Controller. Das wird mit USB gesteuert. Ja, warum denn nicht? Ja, warum nicht? Ich meine, du kannst ein Raumschiff steuern, womit du willst. Natürlich kannst du auch so einen Playstation-2-Controller nehmen. Voll. Ohne Scheiss, im A380 muss auch der Joystick also, wir sehen es nicht, aber der Joystick hat ein Kabel, wird zu dem Hauptrechner gehen und Chance ist, es ist ein USB-Kabel. Ja klar. Der Joystick ist nicht so weit weg von einem scheiß USB-Maus. Ja, nur weil der fest in das Armaturenbrett gebaut ist und dadurch so cool aussieht, heisst das nicht, dass man den auch einfach abnehmen könnte und schön auf dem Sofa, im Grunde könntest du in so Cockpit ein Sofa stellen und da einfach den Piloten mit dem Playstation-2-Controller hinsetzen. Dann sagt er, ja, ich nehme den Controller, lieber Praktikant, und dann reden wir über Sachen. Und dann plötzlich stellt der Praktikant die Frage, die sich das ganze Publikum auch schon fragt. Wann hört der Film endlich auf? Ja, und dann wird kurz gelacht. Aber die nächste Frage, die er stellt, ist Timothy Chalamet übrigens, der Praktikant. Ja! Falschrum, aber auf dem Kopf. Aber auch da immer noch Schönheit. Immer noch gut. Fragt, Leute, ist jeder Wasserplanet auch ein Felsplanet? Gut, dass du es sagst, deswegen fliegen wir zu Exposition, Exposition, Exposition. Wir fliegen zu diesem Wasserplaneten hin. Pandori. Zu Pandor. Panda. Pandori. Pandorio. Findet Pandori. Okay, unsere Mission lautet Finding Pandori. Ei, ei, ei, ei, ei. Um Dreiecken. So. Weil, vergiss nicht, woher wir kamen, den erfolgreichsten Film aller Zeiten. Richtig, es gibt nämlich auf dem Schiff auch dritte Klasse, zweite Klasse, erste Klasse, Premium-Klasse. Die Aliens aus District 9. Ja. Weil da wurde ja schon damals gezeigt, dass Aliens in so einem Slum-artigen Strukturen wohnen. Genau, es gibt sozusagen einen ganzen Slum-Bereich auf dem Raumschiff. Wo immer Hip-Hop läuft. Das ist auch immer weird, dass man so Slum... Genau, aber so spanischer Hip-Hop. Ja. Und bitte hör auf, bitte auf, bitte auf. Also acht Arme werden geschwungen. Lass die Schultern bitte, steck die Schulter wieder ein. Acht Schultern durch acht Arme werden geschwungen.
19 Hüften, die Aliens haben 19 Hüften, die alle gleichzeitig herumsprachen. In unserer Aliensprache wird dazu gesungen.
Ja, und natürlich, da verliebt sich einer in die Kapitänin.
Was?
Die Kapitänin.
Wer jetzt?
Gespielt von Kylie Minogue.
Kylie Minogue.
Ja, ist eine Doppelrolle.
Kylie Minogue, aber ihr innerer Monolog wird immer von Kylie Minogue. Charlize Theron. Ja, ist eine Doppelrolle. Charlize Theron, aber ihr innerer Monolog wird immer von Kylie Minogue gesungen. Und weil wir für den Soundtrack auch noch ein paar Promis brauchen. Und Musicals auch immer Publikum ziehen. Richtig. Weiß ich nicht. Die verlieben sich ineinander natürlich. Timothy Chalamet und Charlize Theron? Nein, nein, nein, nein, das Alien und Charlize Theron, genau. Und dann, kurz bevor sie ihre Liebe konsumieren können und die erste Liebesnacht verbringen,
schlägt das Raumschiff ein auf dem Wasserplaneten.
Moment, landet. Du meinst, es landet hechtartig.
Nee, volle Lotte.
Sie fliegen dagegen.
Ja, was heißt dagegen? Rein.
Sie fliegen in den Planeten rein.
Und dann überall Bläschen, Fische.
Fische?
Man guckt zum Fenster raus. Es fliegt überall überall die Wasserschlieren und es wird immer dunkler. Mhm. So, Frage. Ende. Teil zwei. Ende. Ende. Und wenn der nichts einspielt, dann machen wir keinen Teil zwei. Das ist das Weilenste. Die letzte, dann kommt dann wieder die Texttafel,
kommen wieder die Buchstaben. Wenn der
Film nicht
genug einspielt, gibt es keinen Teil
zwei.
Es liegt nur an euch.
Wenn ihr wissen wollt, wie es
da geht, schaut ihn euch direkt
noch mal an. Außerdem geht noch mal ein Hut
rum.
Am Ausgang steht ein Kasten. Jeder schmeißt da was rein. So. Ihr James Cameron. Ich würde gerne wissen, sind Wasserplaneten Steinsplaneten, oder? Und dann wäre es Titanic geil angeklungen, Eis. Eisplaneten. Und sie fliegen in den Wasserplatten rein, gegen Eis.
Bip, bip, bip, Captain, wir konnten kein Gestein orten.
Dann rasen Sie weiter. Dann rasen Sie bitte in der halsbrecherischen Geschwindigkeit weiter. Ja, Captain!
Bip, bip, bip, bip, bip!
Moment mal, was ist das?
Bip, bip, bip, bip! Es kann kein Gestein sein!
Und Ende.
Ja!
Nee?
Wie ist das die Post-Credit-Scene übrigens gerade?
Aber Timothy Chalamet übrigens. Was ist das? Bip, bip, bip, bip, es kann kein Gestein sein. Und Ende. Ja.
Nee, das ist die Post-Credit-Scene übrigens gerade.
Aber Timothy Chalamet überlebt.
Wissen wir nicht. Wissen wir am Ende des ersten Teils nicht.
Wissen wir nicht. Er ist raus, er ist über Bord gegangen.
Über Bord gegangen?
Praktikant über Bord. Wir sehen ihn nur, Chalamet mit wahnsinniger Geschwindigkeit am Fenster vorbeiziehen.
Wir wissen nicht, was mit ihm passiert. Schiffbruch mit Praktikant, das ist der deutsche sperrige Untertitel. Finding Pandory. Auf Englisch heißt er Perspectives, Finding Pandory und auf Deutsch ist er Praktikant über Bord mit Timothy Chalamet. Gut. Die Marketing-Kamane ist eine Katastrophe. Ich glaube, wir sollten dringend mal ein Drehbuch schreiben. Das meine ich ganz unironisch. Einfach mal ein Drehbuch schreiben. Weil warum nicht? Haben wir nicht gerade eins geschrieben. Können wir das nicht schicken? Schicken an wen? Ja, genau. Cameron. An wen kann man denn mal so einen richtigen Blockbuster schicken? Hier in Deutschland kann man das nicht produzieren. Falls ihr ein Hollywood-Regisseur oder Regisseurin seid und euch gehen die Ideen aus. Ihr sagt, ja, ich habe einen Namen in Hollywood, ich habe mir ein Standing erarbeitet, ich habe vielleicht schon Oscar-Statuete im Schrank stehen, aber mir gehen die Ideen aus. Und das ist ja unangenehm zu sagen. Weil es ist ja oft so ... Sind Sie ein Hollywood-Regisseur und Ihnen gehen die Ideen aus?
Peinlich, oder?
Dann haben wir was für Sie.
Rufen Sie an unter 0171. Weil das ist ja auch oft so, wenn ein Film rauskommt, das finde ich immer die unverschämteste Frage, muss ich ganz ehrlich mal sagen, liebe Filmreporter, lasst es, wenn ein Film rauskommt und Cameron sitzt da mit Avatar 9 und die Leute sagen, Mr Cameron, do you have any informations for us about your next project? Und als Cameron würde ich sagen, ich sitze hier gerade mit Avatar 9, schau dir doch erst mal an. Fuck you, fuck you, fuck you. So, lass uns doch erst mal darüber reden, immer nicht das nächste Projekt. Und ich habe noch nie auf diese Frage die Antwort gehört, nö, ich habe jetzt erst mal frei. Alle sagen, ja, ja, I can't talk about it right now, but there is a lot of exciting stuff coming up. Aber niemand sagt so, nee, im Niesin, ich bin blank. Ja, man fahrt ja auch nicht Fussballern nach dem Spiel, ob sie jetzt gespannt sind aufs nächste Spiel. Ja. Habt ihr schon wieder Lust aufs nächste Spiel? Nein, es ist erst mal, wir reden über das Spiel, was gerade passiert ist. Nein, wenn irgendjemand ein neues Musikalbum rausbringt, immer, woran arbeitest du als nächstes? Und als Cameron willst du nicht sagen, ich bin blank, ich habe keine Ideen mehr, mein Kopf ist leer. Aber das muss nicht sein, die Das Podcast Ufo Hotline, die Ghostwriter. Wir sind Ghostwriter. Aber wir wollen mit unserem eigenen Namen da stehen. Kurz aufflackern bitte im Abspann. Aber nicht zu schnell bitte. Wir haben massive Probleme mit den Gesundheitsorganisationen dieser Welt. Also, Cami, falls du keine Ideen mehr hast, schreib uns gerne an. An die Zentrale, zentrale-at podcast-uvo.fail. Ja. Aber ich meine, als Ghostwriter kannst du ja alles behaupten, eigentlich auch, oder? Wenn du als Ghostwriter arbeitest, kannst du dir sagen, ja, ich habe die, ich habe hier Namen. Du kannst ihm nichts sagen, das ist ja ganz geil. Jeder kann behaupten, er ist Ghostwriter, weil es kommen keine Follow-up-Questions. Niemand fragt dann, was waren deine letzten krassen Projekte? Ja, also, normalerweise darf ich das ja nicht sagen, aber dir sage ich es mal, wir kennen uns schon so gut. Ich habe ja Name der Rose geschrieben. Du hast Name der Rose geschrieben? Damals war es so viel. Ja, also wie gesagt, ich habe viel diktiert, meine Eltern haben das aufgenommen und ja, ich habe einen 900 Seiten langen Roman über ein Kloster. Für Umberth und Echo. Für Umberth und Echo habe ich. Weil der hat mich angerufen, Echo meinte und ich so, Echo, what up, was geht? Und der meinte, ich bin hier komplett blank, ich habe keine Zeit, meine Küche ist unter Wasser, kannst du mir nicht einen Roman schreiben? Mach was du willst, go nuts. Hat er dir irgendwas gesagt? Hat er gesagt Kloster? Nee, nee, nee, gar nicht. Er hat nur gesagt, go nuts. Go nuts? Ja, go nuts gesagt. So ist im Namen der Rosaschen go nuts. Im Grunde verrückt heute, kann man sich ja gar nicht vorstellen. Und dann habe ich eben gesagt, okay, pass auf, Echo, ich mache das für dich eine Bedingung, eine einzige Bedingung. Du willst in Marwam bezahlt werden. Und ich will, dass wir jedes Wochenende Minigolf spielen gehen. Und dann warst du mit Umberto Eco jedes Wochenende Minigolf spielen? Jedes Wochenende, seit man ist ja Roman rauskommen, vor 40 Jahren oder so, war ich tatsächlich jedes Wochenende mit Umberto Eco Minigolf spielen. Und meine Frage, die ich jetzt dazu als Darsteller stellen möchte, ist, wurde Umberto Eco merklich besser im Minigolf? Er hat schlecht angefangen und er ist immer noch sehr schlecht. Ja? Also er kaum... Man würde ja meinen, wenn du so viele Stunden verbringst mit Minigolf, dass du irgendwann sehr gut bist. Tatsächlich nicht. Ich würde sogar behaupten, wenn du so oft Minigolf spielst, bist du in den Top Ten der Welt. Nee, ich bin mittlerweile, glaube ich, gute Acht unter Paar, Acht mal Handicap, also richtig gut. Wow. Er ist immer noch im Bogey-Mode. Also Echo ist im Umberto ist im Bogey-Mode. Und also wie gesagt, ein einziges Mal tatsächlich in den 90ern hatte er einmal ein Hold'n'One. Ein einziges Mal. Was für ein Hindernis war das? Das war so ein Pendel. Ja, gut, kann man jetzt natürlich auch darauf eingehen. Das war so ein großes Pendel. Und das war tatsächlich die Idee für sein nächstes Buch. Und da hat er gesagt, pass auf, Ghosty, hier habe ich jetzt ein Hold-in-One bekommen bei dem großen Pendel-Parcours. Lass uns da doch noch ein Buch drüber schreiben.
Und hast du seitdem alle Bücher für Umberto Eco geschrieben? Nein, nein, nein. Hat der auch andere Ghostwriter? Hat der überhaupt was selber geschrieben? Wie gesagt, Ghostwriter, das ist so eine Art Ehrenkodex, dass man sich nicht verrät, aber ich sag mal so, das Foucault'sche Pendel hat auch nicht Umberto Eco geschrieben. Ah, okay. Also das ging dann an jemand anderen. Und ich war aber stolz natürlich bei dem Entstehungsmoment dabei zu sein gewesen, zu sein mit diesem Pendel-Moment. Das war in den 90ern. Wow, ja vielen Dank. Ja, das war der einzige Hole in one. Wir stellen Berufe vor, ab jetzt jede Woche stellen wir Berufe vor. Ja, freut mich auch sehr, dabei zu sein. Wie gesagt, falls Sie gerade einen Song hören, vielleicht habe ich ihn geschrieben. Songs, das schreibst du auch? Ich schreib auch Songs. Was schreibst du alles? Hauptsächlich Rap, also schneller Sprechgesang, je schneller das je besser. Auf Deutsch oder? Viel für Metal, Deutsch, Holländisch, das auf jeden Fall, das ist so meine Ecke. Weißt du, was du bist der talentierteste Mensch der Welt? Ach na ja. Wenn du mit vier den Namen der Rose geschrieben hast. Na ja. Ja, ist schon krass. Ja gut, das schreibt sich ja von selbst, Klostermännchen. Was soll dann passieren? Was soll groß passieren? Ja, das stimmt. Was machen Sie beruflich? Ich stelle Fragen. Ah, spannend. Ich stelle, aber die Fragen habe ich mir nicht selbst ausgedacht. Die hat mir einen... Ganz recht, ganz recht. Das glaube ich jetzt nicht. Sie, Sie haben mir die Fragen gestellt. Das ist das Drehbuch, das Sie abgegeben haben, ein Ghostwriter, der sich seine eigenen Fragen stellt. James Cameron, das ist ihr nächster Film. Wie gesagt, ich bin blank. Well, it was an idea, I had it in my mind for a long time. And it was like a passion project for me, because in my youth I came up with the idea of a Ghostwriter. I worked as a Ghostwriter myself, and it's a tough job. I was a ghostwriter, and I was a ghostwriter. It's a very exciting job. He's slow, man. He's slow. I'm going to talk slower. I'm going to talk slower. And so I had to do all the Titanic-Avatar stuff to earn a little bit of the money, the money, to give me some juice, some juice, some saft raus, some gas in my engine and now I can go full throttle and move on. Ich kann jetzt folgernächtig über, um mir aufs nächste Projekt zu gehen. Ghostwriter thing, which I'm interested in. Ja, der letzte Satz war nicht für lange. Ja, aber es gibt ja, ich dachte mir das jetzt auch, ich kann das live. Ich kann, ich habe jetzt am Wochenende eine Formel 1 geguckt, ging wieder los, schwand, schwand, schwand, rasen, rasen, rasen. Und da gibt es dann am Ende immer einen Übersetzer, der die englischen Interviews als Deutsch übersetzt. Und ich glaube, ich könnte das genauso schnell live machen. Andersrum gar nicht. Aber ich glaube, ich könnte Englisch simultan auf Deutsch übersetzen. Aber meinst du nicht, dass da ein Wort kommt, das du nicht kennst und darüber stolperst du? Dann hört man so ein durchblättern. Ach hier, nee, Chandelier. Nee, Cheetah, Chandelier, ah, Kronleuchten.
Warum sollte Lewis Hamilton von einem Kronleuchten... Aber jetzt mal ernsthaft, liebe Zuschauer.
Naja, du willst jetzt sagen, Sportler sind dumm und benutzen keine grossen Worte.
Nee, und was hat Kronleuchten mit Formel 1 zu tun?
Die Frage war, wie war das Rennen für ihn, und freut er sich schon aufs nächste Rennen? and he's happy to be on the next race. completely free to go as fast as i wanted which is great and i jesus i was hitting that that jesus thing it was so fast so schnell all around me was just a blur and i was so so fast i mean i sometimes i thought i will just take off and fly away i will fly away just a little bit faster and will fly away and i was going, faster. Guys were cheering. And well, in the end I came in last, which is... Oh, da bin ich letzter geworden. I didn't even know there was a race going on, to be honest. I was just having fun. Those cars, dude, you can't imagine, it doesn't even look that fast on television. It sieht gar nicht so schnell aus, wenn man es auf Fernsehen schaut. But if you're in one... Wow! Wow, it's fast. Man, it is, you really have to try it. I'm crying. You really have to try it. I weine, it's you have to try it. And which is strange because that one curve in the forest, there was like somebody installed a big chandelier there. And I was so, so taken aback by it and because it was reflecting the light. Im Wald. Und da hat jemand einen grossen ...
... so, so taken aback by it,
and because it was reflecting the light
in my eyes, and I was like for a moment
like, whoa, what was that? Oh, it was just
a chandelier. So, I
continued to ...
I mean, I was so fast.
It went by in a split second.
Kronleuchter!
Kronleuchter! Da hat jemand einen Kronleuchter aufgegangen und dann war es irgendwie hell. Danke für die Frage und ich werde mein ... Danke für die Frage. Ich werde es feiern. Ich werde es machen. Ich werde es machen. Es war zu viel Spaß gemacht. Bye. Ciao. Ja, kannst du richtig gut.
Ich kann das ganz gut.
Kannst du richtig gut.
Chandelier.
Ich habe ein neues Wort gelernt, weil man denkt ja, ja, ich habe 16 Staffeln Friends auf Englisch gesehen, ich kann Englisch.
Nein, kannst du nicht.
Du kennst viele Worte nicht, wie zum Beispiel das Wort Escarpment.
Escarpment?
Escarpment, weißt du nicht, was das heißt?
Wir sind wahrscheinlich die allermeisten nicht, was das bedeutet.
Ausscherbung.
Nein, es ist keine Ausscherbung.
Das war es für mich. Escarpment. Escarpment? Escarpment, weißt du nicht, was das heißt? Wir sind wahrscheinlich die allermeisten nicht, was das bedeutet.
Ausscherbung. Nein, es ist keine Ausscherbung. Das deutsche Wort kenne ich jetzt allerdings wieder nicht. Also das ist jetzt, okay. Also eine Auslassung. Nein, es ist eine Steilstufe. Steilstufe? Auch das deutsche Wort kenne ich nicht. Es ist eine Steilstufe, das ist wenn du eine ebene Fläche hast, ein Land, also das sind geografischer oder geologischer Begriffe, da überschneiden sich die ja, die Felder ja oft, und wenn du hast eine flache Fläche und dann eine steile Stufe, also es wird schlagartig höher. Also wie so ein Escarpment. Ein bisschen wie ein Escarpment. Es wird schlagartig höher und dann aber wieder flach. Also du hast Flachland getrennt von einer Steinstufe. Klippe. Lange Klippe. Aber Klippe ist ja oft zwischen Land und Wasser, aber da ist es zwischen Land und Land. Warum sollte es das geben? Was hat sich die Natur dabei gesagt? Ja, verrückt, dass man vielleicht irgendwie mit tektonischen Platten, das war die Antwort eines jeden Dialogen, so, da ist hier mitten in Mailand, mitten in der Innenstadt ist ein Riesenvulkan ausgebrochen, alles war warm, das ganze Eis ist geschmolzen, das gesamte Eis in der gesamten Stadt ist geschmolzen, riesige Umsatzverluste für alle Eisdehnen. Warum, Herr Professor Griebenstock, Sie waren nicht live in Mailand anwesend, Sie sind Institutsleiter des Geologischen Instituts Stuttgart an der Universität Mainz. Zwei Wörter für Sie. Ja, zwei Wörter. Tektonische Platten. Drei Wörter. Tektonische Platten. Das ist ja hochinteressant. Sie sagen, dass mitten in Mailand der Vulkan ausgebrochen ist, weil dort können Sie ja vielleicht … Tektonische Platten, tektonische Platten, tektonische Platten.
Und das heißt, die sind aneinander geriehen? Tektonische Platten. Jetzt, ich glaube, wir kommen der Sache näher, also eine schiebt sich unter die andere und durch die entstehende Hitze, die Reibung, ist so viel Wärme entstanden, dass das Gestein sich in Lava, in Magma verwandelt hat und dann aus der Stadt geschossen ist. Technologische Platten. Herr Grimstock, vielen, vielen Dank, dass Sie sich die Zeit genommen haben. Ich wünsche noch einen schönen Tag. Manche Profe sind nicht klar. Nein, zurückführen. Und da habe ich jetzt schon Angst. Ich habe ordentlich, es hat mich geschüttelt die letzten Wochen. Ich war angsterfüllt und dachte, war es das jetzt? Weil es kam raus, der Ätna ist ja wieder aktiv. Nein! Und nicht nur der Ätna. Krabappel! Nicht nur Krabappel ist aktiv, nein, auch alle anderen Vulkane der Welt zeigen gewisse Aktivität. Und die Geologen wissen nicht genau, was da los ist gerade. Die Seismografen drehen durch, man fragt sich, was los ist, aber wahrscheinlich tetonische Platten. Aber auf jeden Fall nimmt gerade die vulkanische Aktivität extrem zu. Man weiß nicht genau, warum Das passiert gerade während wir sprechen. Während wir sprechen, sind alle Vulkane gerade am Start. Irgendwas ist da unten, geht vor sich. Was ist der näheste Vulkan an uns gerade? Eifel. Ist es die Eifel? Nein, die Eifel. Du musst nicht nach Italien gucken. Nein, direkt neben uns ist die Eifel. Die Leit ist ja Eifel weg. Eine Autostunde. Und jetzt eine Lavastunde? Also wie viele Lavastunden sind eine Autostunde? Oh, 30 Lavastunden. 30 Lavastunden. Also wenn der ausbricht und die Lava macht sich auf mich? Wir machen uns jetzt vor unfassbar viel Zeit vor der Gefahr, davon zu laufen. Das ist schon reicht. Wir können laufen und wir würden schaffen. Selbst wenn du die Hälfte der Zeit schläfst, also angenommen, der würde ausbrechen, direkt nachdem du eingeschlafen bist, schläfst du zehn Stunden, dann dauert es vielleicht noch ein paar Stunden, bis du es liest, auf Twitter, und dann kannst du noch weglaufen. Wenn die Eifel ausbricht, ist es süss. Man freut sich. Also das ist wie so ein kleiner Geysir. Und da denkt man ja auch in Deutschland, ein bisschen lame, also wir sind mit der Natur, glaube ich, Deutschland ist kein Naturland, so richtig, weil wir nicht diese Extremen haben. Wir haben nicht diese tektonischen Platten, wir haben nicht diese. Ach so, deswegen. Jetzt habe ich es verstanden, weil wir keine Platten haben. Wir haben nicht diese Escarpments, wir haben keine krasse Natur, das ist mein Satz. Wir haben keine krasse Natur. Okay haben so eine Tutorial-Natur, also Staatland. Ja, wir haben die seienste Map bei Siedler. Ein kleiner Hügel und Wald. Aber wer die Schlagzeile dann, die Eifel ist Lava? So was. Die Eifel ist Lava, wenn da der Wohlstand. Achtung, Eifel ist Lava. Vorsicht, die Eifel ist Lava.
Okay, dann halte ich mich da...
Dafür habe ich mein Leben lang drin.
I know the drill.
Get on my chair.
Get on the sofa.
Die Eifel ist Lava.
Ich bin lächerlich gut
darauf vorbereitet.
Das ist mein Moment.
Jetzt bin ich bereit. Und deine Eltern so, wir dachten, das wäre Quatsch, aber der Junge hat sich vorbereitet. Er hat alle Vasen runtergeschmissen in seiner Jugend, aber er weiss, was er tut, er weiss verdammt nochmal, was er tut. Er weiss, was er macht, damit der Boden ist Lava. Also du legst dich fest, die nächste grosse Katastrophe ist Vulkanausbruch. Katastrophchen. Katastrophen, ja. Gibt es das Wort? Das finde ich ein schönes Wort. Man kann nicht alle Wörter verniedlichen. Es spricht sich ein bisschen. Tragödchen. Es wird ein Tragödchen, es wird ein Katastrophen. Wenn die Eifel ausbricht, ist es so, glaube ich, einfach süss anzugucken. Weil wir haben nicht, weißt du, in den USA haben die den Supervulkan. Die haben den,stone, das ist ein Supervulkan. Wenn der ausbricht, dann geht die Welt unter. Die fucking unkreativ sind eigentlich Geologen, oder? Kann man sich da nicht ein neues Wort ausdenken? Ja, und hier in der Vulkaneifel passiert, glaube ich, nicht so viel. Und deswegen, glaube ich, haben wir auch als Deutsche so ein bisschen den Kontakt verloren. Das Krasse, was wir haben, sind ein paar Berge im Süden, und deswegen sind wir Deutschen das Bergwanderfolg. Deswegen lieben viele Deutsche die Berge. Ja, vor allem, was man oft vergisst bei Vulkanen, man denkt, Vulkane sind heiß und sind hell und es sieht krass aus. Aber was man oft vergisst, ist der Geruch. Stinken. Vulkane stinken wie Hölle nach Schwefel. Ich war ja am Visuf und das ist wirklich unerträglich. Du denkst dir, oh toll, Vulkan, majestätisch, aber es riecht halt einfach nach Ei. Es riecht einfach richtig hart nach Ei. Du fährst zum Visuf und denkst dir, oh Naturspektakel. Und du fährst auf dem Parkplatz und steigst aus dem Auto und denkst dir, Moment mal. Ich finde, wenn, wie heißt es noch mal, Perseverance irgendwann so ein paar Daten schickt und dann so, und PS, der Mars stinkt. Cooler Planet, eindrucksvoll, Naturgewalten am Start. Hier riecht das ja nicht, da unten in der Zentrale. Aber es stinkt. Der Mars stinkt. Vor allem die Bevölkerung des Mars scheitert daran, dass er einfach stinkt. Die ersten Siedler denken, was ist das denn? Hier soll ich wohnen? Er reist drei Jahre mit so einem Raumschiff auf engstem Raum dahin, alles vorbereitet, um den Mars zu kultivieren. Ja, das kann passieren. Das ist so ein konstanter Schweißgeruch. Um den Mars zu kultivieren. Sieht man dem was schönes an. Jeans. Stinkt halt, Mars. Mars stinkt. Dann braucht man so eine interdimensionale Deo-Flasche, die die NASA steht. Riesige Deo-Flaschen. Und das ist wie so eine Sintflut, das einmal Axe-Body-Spray gesponsert, einmal kommt... Da haben wir doch einen Film. Über den Mars. Der Mars stinkt und James Cameron fliegt. Ja, Mars müffelt. Britannic ist nämlich eine grosse... Genau, es ist eine Deodose. Es ist eine riesen Deodose. Das Raumschiff und es richtet sich dann so auf und dann... Und dann wird die... Aber was die alle nicht berechnet haben, die krassen Wissenschaftler, ist, dass der Rückstoß so extrem ist, dass die Deodose ins Weltall, mit Timothy Chalamet, der noch draufgeblieben ist, praktikant in Deodose ins Weltall geschossen wird. Oder der böse Praktikant, oder genau, weil die nicht zusammenleben können, sagen die jetzt, wir wollen sterben, und dann wirft einer ein Feuerzeug in den Deostral, in diesen riesigen Deostral, entzündet das Ganze, riesiges Flammen.
Mars stinkt, Mars brennt.
Mars brennt, ja, Mars. NASA peinlich. Sorry, aber der Mars brennt. Wie konnte das passieren?
Kann jemand einen Ghostwriter engagieren, wenn das... Hier ist für Sie Billie Eilish!
So ein Pausenprogramm.
Pausenprogramm in Pressekonferenzen.
Bevor ich Ihre Frage beantworte...
Billie Eilish!
Und auch...
Woo!
Yay!
Ja, das ist genial.
Der Mars stinkt, aber es ist tatsächlich so, Vulkane riechen ganz unangenehm.
Und ich glaube, man stellt sich das auch anders, cooler vor, als es ist. Riesen-Vulkanausbruch, alles krass. Aber den Ström ja primär, gut, primär, nehme ich zurück, auch Gase, ganz viel, nicht nur Magma, solange es in der Luft ist, ist es noch Magma.
Gas, ach so.
Sondern auch ganz viele Gase, Schwefel und es stinkt einfach.
Ich hatte irgendwie, weil dieser Vulkan sieht ja auch aus wie so eine Art Eierbecher.
Aber er sieht ja wirklich so aus wie ein Vulkan, den man malt als Kind.
Ja, aber der ist zu.
Wie, der sieht ja nicht so aus. Nee, nee, es ist schon ein Vulkan und der hat auch diese Einwölbung oben, wie eine grosse Eierschale. Und du hast halt, du denkst dir, das sieht aus wie eine grosse Eierschale und es riecht halt auch nach Ei. Und ich stelle mir halt in dem Vulkan so ein riesiges Ei. Es wäre halt geil, wenn so ein Riesenhuhn vorbeiläuft und so ein riesiges Ei da drin. Genau da ein Ei legt.
Aber warum... Vielleicht waren das die Dinosaurier,
waren ja quasi Hühner. Hör jetzt auf.
Und vielleicht haben die...
Ihr hättet es schon ein paar Mal gesagt, dass du aufhören soll.
Hättet es im Vulkan nichts anderes als der Ort, wo die ihre Eier
abgelegt haben. Kann auch sein.
Und damit es warm und damit es auch schön warm gehalten.
Sehr gut, ausgebrütet.
Wie interagieren Tiere mit Vulkanen?
Ich glaube, beten es an.
Ja?
Also mit der Eifel.
Mit der Eifel wird so gesprochen wie mit so einem zurückgebliebenen Kind. Ja, hallo, hallo, hallo, schön warm, bisschen warm, bisschen heiss macht sie hier.
Aber ganz kurz, warum ist der Vesuv zu?
Der ist aus. Wie? Der ist aus. Hast du ihn ausgemacht? Nein, ich weiß nicht, wer ihn ausgemacht hat. Fuck, ich habe den Vesuv angelassen. Oh, Mama Mia! Scheiße! Der Vesuv ist noch an. Italienischer Präsident entschuldigt sich, ich habe den Vesuv angelassen. Also nee, aber das ist schon so, weil, ich meine, angenommen, wie sieht denn das Ende eines Vulkanausbruchs aus? Wir stellen uns das vor. Lava, Lava, stinkt, stinkt. Schussige Fontänen, aber irgendwann hat der auch keinen Bock mehr, hat der keinen Dampf mehr auf dem Kessel. Aber dann schieb ich mir so vor, dass dann einfach das Loch ist, unten sehen wir noch Lava. Genau. Und die Lava kühlt ja irgendwann aus. Wieso? Ja, weil das Schluss ist. Wieso ist das Schluss? Der Ausbruch ist zu Ende. Und oben kühlt es halt ab über Jahre und dann ist es halt ausgekühlt. Diese vage Sprache, die da drin ist. Und dann geht man da hin und steigt aus dem Auto aus
und läuft da hoch.
In diesem Reisebus.
In diesem Schwefelmeer und guckt da rein und sagt, ja,
da ist aber schon noch was los.
Also da gibt es schon noch so kleine Schwefel.
Er macht wirre Handbewegungen, ganz wirre,
flamencoartige Handbewegungen.
Ich will nicht sagen Fontäne, aber ich kann mich schon erinnern, dass da so Gas sowieso leck ist. Du weißt nicht mehr, was da passiert ist. Ich weiß noch, dass ich Asche mitgenommen habe, das war aber nicht der Vesuv, sondern Pompeji. In Pompeji hast du dir, das war aber Edna, Edna hat damals Pompeji kaputt gemacht. Der Aetna ... Oh, habe ich jetzt Aetna und Vesuv verwechselt? Ja, ich weiß nicht genau. Ist der Vesuv ... Ja, Aetna, du hast recht. Aetna hat Pompeji zerstört? Ich muss kurz gucken. Ah, fuck. Oh Mann, ich war da und hab ... Ja. ich war da und hab, warum reist man eigentlich?
Weiß ich, ich weiß auch nichts mehr. Warum reist man? Jetzt hab ich gesehen, dass, keine Ahnung, hier, obwohl Corona ist, sind wahnsinnig viele zu diesen Chichen Itza, zu der Maya Pyramide, wo ich ja auch war. Wegen dir. Und ich weiß nichts mehr über, ich hab auch so gedacht, stimmt, ich war ja bei den Maya Pyramiden, ich weiß nichts mehr über die Mayas. ja reisen kann man sich kaufen aber die die Erinnerung, Vesuv, guck mal, Pompeji war eine antike Stadt in Kampanien am Golf von Neapel, die wie Herkula beim Ausbruch des Vesuvs. Aha, doch Vesuv, na also. Puh! Oh, das war 50-50, wirklich. Also, ich sehe jetzt extrem intelligent aus gerade. Die Leute werden jetzt ... Du warst der Erste, der gesagt hat, Besuch, wuh, Besuch, Besuch! Mit so grossen Finger, also Besuch-Finger. Haltet mich bitte nicht für intelligenter, als ich bin. Es war einfach 50-50. Niemand hält dich für intelligenter. Es war Abspurs Glück. Also jetzt nicht, ich weiß, vielleicht liegt irgendwo noch die Quiz-U-Boot-Bewerbung rum und die Leute sagen jetzt, lad den mal ein, der ist richtig schlau. Nein, lasst es, lasst es, ich bin mittlerweile auch grösser, die Grössenangaben stimmen nicht mehr. Die können den Stuhl unmöglich so weit runterfahren. Nee, du müsst auf dem Boden sitzen. Krass, Besuch, guter Name, guter, starker Name. Edna hingegen? Hm, nee, schwierig. Aber Namen sind echt das Schlimmste, weil ich bin jetzt auch gerade in Vorbereitung auf ein neues Pen & Paper,
wobei Rocket Beans TV. Tabor geht weiter. Geht in die zweite Runde. Und das Schlimmste am Schreiben von solchen Abenteuern und Geschichten sind einfach die Namen. Meinst du jetzt Namen von Dingen? Namen von Orten, von Städten, von Flüssen, von Gebirgen, von Personen. Weil Namen zeichnen sich, das habe ich nämlich auch beim Schreiben immer das Problem, Namen werden erst zu Namen durch Redundanz. Also Vesuv klingt super seltsam, wenn du es zum ersten Mal hörst. Aber je häufiger es Leute in einem ganz normalen alltäglichen Kont ich, die Kontextuierung von Namen, machen es erst zu Namen. Deswegen ist es auch so schwierig, sich in Podcastnamen auszudenken oder in Bandnamen, weil niemand hinterfragt Silbermond mehr als Bandnamen, weil es halt so oft benutzt wurde im normalen Kontext und niemand lacht dabei oder der Name an sich wird nicht mehr Thema, wenn man darüber spricht, aber in dem Moment, wo man zum ersten Mal darüber spricht, ist es halt weird as fuck. Und du brauchst ja so viele, also du musst ja so, wenn du so eine ganze Pen-and-Paper-Welt baust, dann musst du ja so eine ganze Zone, also Gegend machen. Und da brauchst du schon mal fünf Städte, drei Flüsse, fünf Gebirge, drei Grafen, vier Fürsten. Man erlaubt sich immer das eine Flussland oder so. Ja, genau. Man erlaubt sich immer den einen. Einen darf man cheaten. Den einen schenkt man sich. Ja, und dann einfach brauchst du so eine ganze Liste. Und ich kann auch nicht schreiben, wenn ich den Namen nicht habe. Wenn ich sage, und der Fürst. Und dann muss ich erst mal zwei Stunden lang den Namen finden und klicke mich durch die Wikipedia alles Mögliche durch. Und es klingt einfach alles bescheuert. Aber du merkst, irgendwie klingt alles, was es gibt, schon richtig richtig cool und alles, was du dir ausdenkst, klingt richtig bescheuert. Klingt erfunden, eben ausgedacht. Die Lombardei, so Begriffe für Gebiete, nicht Städte, sondern Gebiete wie die Lombardei. Italien ist das einzige Land, wo wir als Deutsche Deutsche Begriffe haben. Oh nein, hör auf, hör auf.
Lombardei, wo haben wir das noch?
Wo haben wir das noch? Du wurdest korrigiert.
Wo haben wir das noch?
Du wurdest korrigiert, du wurdest getestet, du wurdest gewogen, du wurdest für nicht gut genug gefunden.
Obwohl ich einen besseren belehrt wurde.
Stefan, gib auf, hör auf.
Ich laufe in die Richtung.
Leg das weg, leg das weg jetzt, leg das weg, hör auf jetzt damit.
So funktioniert es nicht. Lombardei, wo wir das noch? Nein, ja in Barcelona, in Warschau, ganz viele Ballspiele. Aber Gebiete, das ist neu. Soll ich noch mehr nennen, soll ich noch mehr nennen? Warschau. Nein, nein, du hast schon recht, das funktioniert so nicht. Das funktioniert so nicht. Das war dein großer Wurf und du hast einfach nicht getroffen. Nee, ich habe nicht nur nicht getroffen, sondern in die falsche Richtung geworfen. Du hast von der Mittellinie geschossen, hättest fast getroffen, aber nicht gemerkt. Zwei Leute dabei verletzt. Ist schon mal jemand beim Sperrwerfen verletzt worden? Da habe ich mich mal gefragt. Ja, glaube ich schon. So einfach aber getötet worden? Also ich glaube, ich habe ein Gift gesehen, wo einer so einen Linienrichter das in den Fuss kann aber auch gefakt kann man kann darüber lachen vor allem auch der so diese dieser stab hochsprung auch dane wie oft das da abbricht und irgendwie ins publikum fliegt und so das ist alles so gefährlich ich würde das echt nicht machen wollen stab hochsprung ja oder auch weitsprung ist so gefährlich in diesen sandkasten ja wenn da noch irgendwie eine schaufel liegtel liegt oder so. Nee, weil wenn dann Publikum vielleicht Sand ins Auge bekommt. Oh ja, das ist ein Problem. Oder der Springer oder die laufen vorbei am Sandkasten und können nicht mehr aufgehalten werden. Die können nicht aufgehalten werden. Die sind ja schnell. Ja, die sind schon schnell, ja. Ich meine, so ein Weitspringer, der ist schnell, kann aber auch weit springen. Wohingegen jetzt so ein Sprinter ist nur schnell. Nur schnell. Der könnte nicht. Jeder Weitspringer könnte auch Marathon laufen, äh, 100-Meter-Sprint machen, aber nicht jeder 100-Meter-Springer könnte auch ein guter Weitspringer sein. Aber man probiert schon mal alles durch, oder? Ja, bei solchen speziellen Sachen denke ich mir, du musst auch alles können. Aber wenn man leichter Adlet ist, probiert man schon mal alles aus, Rack, Bock, Stock, Stab, Degen, Degen, dann das, wo man auf Eis das schlittern lässt, und dann Degen, Rapier, Ep, Degen, Kurzschwert, Langschwert, Einhandachst, Zweihandachst, du probierst alles mal durch. Und wir sind wieder bei W. Probierst alles mal durch und sagst dann, also mir lag am meisten das mit der Pistole. Tontaus. Also die Kombination aus Pistole schießen, ein Bild malen und sich 16 Zahlen auswendig merken. Das hat mir am besten gelegen. Das kann ich richtig gut. Was kannst du wirklich gut? Was ist so ein Hiddenteil denn von dir eigentlich? Ich kann also zum Beispiel, ich habe den Stoffball, ich habe einen grünen Stoffball bei mir in der Wohnung. Wie gross ist der? Fussballgross? Ja, Fussballgross, ein bisschen so zwischen Handball und Fussball. Ist der grüne Stoffball von Ikea, kennen vielleicht manche. Und den platziere ich vor mir. Den platzierst du vor dir? Plötzlich vor mir und dann auf der anderen Seite des Raumes steht mein Schreibtisch, der einen rechteckigen Kasten darstellt, die Beine. Du kannst immer treffen, das Tor. Ich, pass auf, zwischen mir und dem Ziel steht noch der Stuhl, der größer ist als der Schreibtisch, so dass ich gezwungen bin zu lupfen, lupfe den grünen Ball über den Stuhl und platziere ihn im Schreibtischtor. Und diese Bewegung habe ich, glaube ich, häufiger gemacht als Messi. Also, glaube ich, könnte ich genau diesen Schuss, nur diesen Schuss, besser machen als Messi. Okay. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Ich verstehe exakt, was du meinst.
Oder was du gerade denkst ist, ja, aber Messi hat ja schon viele andere Schüsse gemacht und dadurch kann er auch den Schuss besser als ich. Ich glaube, er bräuchte nicht so viel Zeit, um das aufzuholen. Gib ihm, glaube ich, einen Tag und er ist besser drin als er. In meiner Wohnung? Ja. Gib Messi einen Tag in deiner Wohnung. Ja, und dann kommt er damit, soll er die Schuhe ausziehen. Der kommt dann da an, er hat auch so eine Tasche mit, so, er hat es gepackt für eine Nacht. Ja, was mache ich währenddessen? Ich sitze am Rechner. Das ist dir überlassen, du kannst da, ich finde das nett, der ist sympathisch. Ich habe nur ein Zimmer, der müsste selber draufzunehmen. Der ist halt nur einen Tag da. Ja, aber dann sitze ich da und gucke YouTube-Videos an, oder was? Du kannst ihm auch unterhalten, ich unterhalte doch mit ihm, das ist vielleicht spannende Sachen zu erzählen. Jalen. Du hast gerade gesagt, er muss einen Tag lang trainieren mit dem grünen Stoffball. Es klang gerade so, als ob es dir unangenehm ist, dass der in deiner Wohnung ist und du da auch bist. Meine Wohnung ist nicht so groß, ich habe nur einen Raum, in dem man so sein kann. Ich finde, du kannst nebenbei irgendwas anderes machen. Das ist ja nur auch, wir reden ja nur von dem Tag. Ja, was soll ich da daneben mal machen? Du kannst auch raus. Ich lasse ja nicht Messi allein in meiner Wohnung. Also, wenn du einen in deiner Wohnung, der macht alles so. Ja, ja, ja. Aber, also könnte das nicht sein, dass wenn du jetzt wirklich seit deinem vierzehnten Lebensjahr einen bestimmten Freistoß von einem bestimmten Platz auf dem Feld jeden Tag hundertmal übst, dass du ihn dann besser kannst als Thorsten Frings? Ich glaube schon, dass das könnte besser als Thorsten Frings. Ich glaube, Thorsten Frings könnte es relativ schnell ähnlich gut, weil er halt andere Schüsse schon achtzig Millionen mal mehr ausprobiert hat. Also du verbringst einen Tag mit Frings, ich verbringe einen Tag mit Bessie. Stefan Tietze aus Carmen wettet, dass, nee, Florian Tietze aus Berchtesgaden, weg, wo kommst du noch mal her, wettet, dass er diesen einen speziellen Schuss mit dem grünen Ball, dem Schreibtisch und dem Hindernis besser hinbekommt als Weltfussballer Lionel Messi. Football-Star Messi. Kann sein. Kann sein. Kann sein, wirklich, kann wirklich sein. Ja, ich weiß nicht, aber vielleicht ist dein Argument auch nicht schlecht, dass dadurch, dass der halt alles kann, besser ist. Es gibt diese Sendung, die ich neulich schauen musste, aus familiären Gründen musste ich gucken, Klein gegen Gross. Das ist eine Sendung, wo kleine Kinder ankommen und die haben dann... Kleine Kinder. Kleine, ganz kleine Kinder. Also sind Kinder, aber dafür auch noch klein. Dafür auch noch klein. Also die sind nicht, weil sie jung sind, sondern Körpergröße. Einfach kleinere Kinder. Nein, das sind einfach Kinder, die kommen dann hin und die haben dann Skills. Das ist im Prinzip Wetten, das. Ganz ehrlich, ist Wetten, das von Kai Pflaume moderiert in der ARD und in Schlecht. Also machen wir uns nichts vor. Also, dann war zum Beispiel irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Aber sind die, nur wenn die Kinder klein sind, auch alle gleich gross? Oder ist es dann schon noch ... Lustigerweise alle exakt gleich gross. Ah, okay. Das kann man sich besser vorstellen. So, und da war zum Beispiel, und dann war es so, die kleine Anna wettet, dass sie, und dann müssen sie immer gegen Promi antreten. Die sagen auch wettet. Nein, behauptet, sagen die, um sich abzugrenzen. Der Anwalt guckt noch mal in die Kamera und nickt. Behauptet, dass, und dann war die Idee, weil die, weil die, weil die, kann die gut turnen, die macht zu turnen. Die kleine Anna turnt. Wie alt ist die? In welchem Alter sind wir? Fünf.
Fünf?
Sechs, ich kann das ganz schnell einschätzen. Sechs, sagen wir sechs.
Ja, eher sieben wahrscheinlich sogar.
Sieben wahrscheinlich.
Jedenfalls hat die dann so ein Sportoutfit an und hat dann schon so Wassergläser.
Und die behauptet, dann hat sie die aufgehoben mit ihren Füssen und dann hat sie sich einmal um sich selber gedreht und hat es dann abgestellt. Okay. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie die Bewegung war, ich habe so wenig Körperverständnis, dass ich mich nicht mehr daran erinnern kann, wie das passiert ist. Die mit den Füssen das Glas genommen und hat sie sich einmal um sich selber gedreht. Und wo, wo, wo, wie war sie mit dem Boden verbunden? Sie saß drauf. Sie saß auf dem Boden? Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob sie saß oder kniet oder so, hat dann jedenfalls mit beiden Füssen das Glas genommen, ist dann einmal als so ein Rückwärts-Kurzelkopp gemacht, sagt man nicht, im Restdeutschland, man sagt Purzelbaum. Leute, schaut euch die Sendung an. Wie beschreibt es, dauert zehn Minuten, die zu beschreiben? Das ist schwierig zu beschreiben. Aber was ich damit sagen will, die Kinder kommen an und haben sehr spezielle Disziplinen, in denen sie behaupten, besser zu sein. Sie jetzt als Lena Gerke, Topmodel, sportliches Topmodel. Und Lena Gerke war fast besser als sie darin. Das heißt, dann kommen diese Kinder da an mit sehr speziellen Talenten und sie machen ja die Regeln. Die Kinder bestimmen ja die Disziplin. Dann kommen die Prominenten an, die dann gegen die antreten und die lernen das dann, weil die in der Probe das dann schon mal machen und sind dann oft besser. Und in dieser Sendung haben bestimmt, weiß ich nicht, sechs Kinder verloren gegen einen Prominenten, weil die erwachsen sind und Dinge besser können. Deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob du besser bist als Lionel Messi. Ja, das stimmt schon. Ich glaube, Messi ist auch älter als ich. Er wäre der Erwachsene in dem, oder? Ja. Muss gar nicht sein. Und das Weirdeste war, dann kam ein Kind an, das liebt so Motocross, so Motorräder, und es ist lustigerweise noch ein kleines Kind, und deswegen fährt es auf einem kleinen Motorrad, was aussieht wie so ein Modellmotorrad, was so ferngestellt werden kann, fährt dann über Hindernisse und so. Und dann hat er behauptet, dass es irgendwie aus 50 Motorrädern jedes am Geräusch des Anlassens erkennen kann. Das ist schon sehr nah. Motorräder. Als die Sendung behaupten das? Klein gegen gross. Ihr Kind behauptet das. Und dann fand ich das super weird und dann hat es behauptet, dann war die Aufgabe, es behauptet, es ist besser, die Motorräder am Geräusch erkennt, als Jürgen Vogel. So, dann kam Jürgen Vogel raus und Jürgen Vogel hat gewonnen. Und ich verstehe nicht, wie. Weil wie kann Jürgen Vogel, Jürgen Vogel liebt angeblich Motorräder, aber du kannst noch nicht 50 Motorräder am Geräusch und dann war das Kind super enttäuscht, obwohl das Kind hat sich die Regeln ausgedacht. Das Kind kannte ja auch die Motorräder. Da kommt Jürgen Vogel. Ja, aber wie unsympathisch ist Jürgen Vogel. Das macht ihn ja fast unsympathisch, dass er jedes Motorrad am Geräusch erkennen kann. Wahnsinn.
Das ist schon gut.
Was ist die Message dieser Sendung? Kinder können nichts.
Selbst das,
was Kinder richtig gut können,
kann ein normaler Erwachsener besser.
Auch zum Stillgreif, ungeprobt
besser. Kinder behaupten
selber,
dass sie zu viel gut können.
Für die nächste Sendung haben wir leider keine Kandidaten mehr, weil die Kinder leider so demoralisiert sind, dass sie nicht mehr einreichen wollen. Ich erkenne, dass ich 20 Scooby-Doo-Comics nur am linken unteren Panel erkennen kann. Und hier ist Uschi Glas. Ja, und Uschi Glas hat gewonnen. Episode 8, ja richtig. Din, din, din, din, din, din, ja, gewonnen. Und dann war eine Schauspielerin da, das ein Kind hat behauptet, ich kann mir besser drei Kartendecks in der richtigen Reihenfolge merken. Das war richtig gruselig. Gemischte Kartendecks aus 52 Karten und die hat man irgendwie eine Stunde Zeit, sie das einzuprägen, dann nochmal eine Stunde Zeit, sich ein neues einzuprägen und so, und dann mussten sie das sortieren und dann hinlegen und so. Und die war, und sie hatte weniger Fehler, die Schauspielerin hatte weniger Fehler als das Kind. Wie lang ist denn die Sendung? Die war ultra lang, die war lang, so wetten das lang. Krass. Genau so lang wie wetten das, auf die Minute genau so lang wie wetten das. Aber finde ich ein geiles Konzept. Das haben wahrscheinlich die Redakteure sich auch anders vorgestellt, dass das läuft.
Man denkt sich, ah, dann gewinnen die Kinder, haha, und dann Jürgen Vogel macht einen lustigen Spruch von wegen, ah, ich kann es nicht so gut, und am Ende einfach nur Trauer und alle weinen und deprimiert.
Das war wirklich extrem weird.
Schaut mal rein, klang gegen Russ, seltsame Sendung.
Bist du wieder so ein bisschen im Fernsehbusiness drin? Nö, nö, nö. Mal gucken, ne? Du guckst einzelne Sachen. Da habe ich nur mal reingeschaut. Ich gucke eigentlich gar nicht mehr Fernsehen. Live-Programm rein? Da habe ich jetzt mal reingeguckt. Weil irgendwie, das ist doch lustig, live zu gucken, ist irgendwie, weiss ich nicht, weckt so nostalgische Gefühle. Ja. Zappen. Das ist ja eigentlich so ein bisschen das kleine TikTok so ein bisschen. Du kannst ja durchzappen. Ich weiß nicht, was du mit TikTok hast. Vielleicht solltest du es auch lassen. Ich bin froh, ich bin stolz auf mich, dass ich die TikTok-App gelöscht habe. Aber jetzt habe ich leider über den Umweg der Instagram-App dieselbe Droge wieder in mir. Ich bin bei TikTok komplett bereit. Ich bin ready. Ich habe mich angezogen mit dem TikTok-Outfit. Und ich bin bereit, dass der Algorithmus mich klaut, dass er mich entführt in die TikTok-Welt. Ich bin bereit, ich ergebe mich dem Algorithmus. Ist so, mach mit mir, was du willst. Absolut, und der Algorithmus nimmt dich an die Hand, mein Lieber. Eben nicht, eben nicht. Nee? Ich hab mir die App runtergeladen, ich hab mir ein paar Leute angeklickt, die ich gut fand, hab mir und war bereit, dass die App mich fängt. Er hat mich nicht gefangen, hat mich am Wegesrand stehen lassen in meinem TikTok-Outfit. Ich glaube, du bist der erste Mensch, der nicht instant TikToks durchtippt. Du nimmst Heroin und sagst, war ganz nett. Ja, auf einmal war okay. Wollen wir heute nochmal Heroin nehmen? Nee, wollen wir nicht. Echt nicht? Nee, ich trinke Wein vielleicht. Aber macht die ruhig. Macht die ruhig. Dann würden wir einfach weiter Heroin nehmen und dann für dich ein Rotwein. Ich habe diesen guten Grauburgunder gefunden. Ja, kann auch sein, dass es auf dich einfach nicht anspringt. Vielleicht bist du immun gegen Aids und immun gegen Süchte. Süchte. Du bist unsuchtbar. Ja. Oder warst du mal süchtig von irgendwas? Nö. Nicht so irgendwie so ein Kaugummi oder so? Nö, nö. Du warst wirklich noch nie von irgendwas süchtig. Warst du doch Nasenspray? Aber das ist auch das härteste Zeug der Welt draußen. Leute, da macht man auch keine Sparspräße. Nasenspray ist, da war ich richtig drauf. Mit zittrigen Händen in Notfallapotheken gegangen.
Das heißt, du hast Nasenspray benutzt, obwohl du gar keine Nasenbeschwerden hast. Ich bin in Apotheken eingebrochen, um Nasenspray zu bekommen. Ich war in dunklen Orten, irgendwo im Bahnhof von Frankfurt, um mir Nasenspray zu besorgen. Hat man das an der Nase angesehen? Nee, das ist das Schlimme da, dass man es nie erkennt. Man erkennt die Opfer nicht. Okay. Also, möchtest du jetzt noch was sagen, für Leute, die vielleicht kurz davor sind, in einer Nasenspray-Sucht abzudriften? Es gibt Anlaufmöglichkeiten, es gibt die Nasenspray-Hotline, 5 für 5 Nase, die könnt ihr anrufen und die helfen euch, da wird euch geholfen. Möchtest du auch als Testimonial auftreten, in Internetkampagnen und Plakatkampagnen? Ich wäre durchaus bereit, als erster deutscher Prominenter, in sehr vielen Anführungszeichen, diese Kampagne zu übernehmen. Nasenspray, nicht mit mir, ist nicht okay, oder so. Ja, oder kann ich nicht gut riechen, oder sowas. Genau. Aber hat das Nebeneffekte, dass man nicht mehr riechen kann, gar nichts? Auf Dauer ja, auf Dauer ist es, glaube ich, ganz schlimm, weil sich, glaube ich, die Schleimhäute dann auflösen und dann so ruiert anfangen so zu schimmeln und dann stinkt man. Man riecht ganz doll, man stinkt, man riecht so eine Stinknase. Was ja natürlich eine Katastrophe ist, aber riechst du dann an deiner eigenen Nase? Das riecht man dann selber nicht. Nee, nee, das riecht man selber nicht. Also andere riechen ... Du riechst wieder wie so. Hast du schon mal an einer anderen Nase gerochen? Selten. Selten, ne? Man riecht selten an Nasen. Nee, aber das stinkt man merklich, glaube ich. Das habe ich mal gelesen. Ich war auch nicht so süchtig. Nein, aber vielleicht, falls euch ein guter Claim einfällt für eine Kampagne gegen Nasenspray, immer der Nase nach, weg vom Nasenspray, sowas in der Richtung und Stefan mit so verschränkten Armen und ernstem Blick daneben, kann ich mir in Großstädten Deutschlands so aus vorstellen. Ich hab's geschafft. Meine Nase ist auch ohne Spray feucht genug, sowas in der Richtung, könnte man vielleicht Stefan gross plakatieren in der grossen Kampagne. Ja, also ich wäre auf jeden Fall bereit, mein Gesicht und mein Körper dafür herzugeben. Weil das ist ein Problem. Ja, nee, absolut. Ja, weil es klingt so ein bisschen lustig. Nein, überhaupt nicht. Aber das ist halt vielleicht, vielleicht hast du deine ganzen Sucht schon abgehakt. Das ist die einzige Sucht, in der ich verfallen bin. Ich. Das heißt schon was. Ich habe noch eine andere Sucht. Das Ende der Folge? Und zwar, ich höre gerne Podcast-Ufo-Folgen. Nächste Woche kommt die nächste raus! Nächste Woche! Jede Woche kommen neue Folgen raus, Leute! Es hört nicht auf, es hört nicht auf. Ich freue mich drauf. Ich bin stolz auf uns, wie krass wir das durchziehen mittlerweile. Ja, klar! Ey, es gab mal andere Zeiten. Ja, da haben wir gesagt, oh ne, heute nicht. Letzte Woche war es Folge 250 und ich dachte mir, das ist ganz schön wenig.
Aber da habe ich mir auch vertan mit Wochen und Tageanzahl im Jahr.
Ich dachte mir, so viel müssen wir noch in einem Jahr haben.
Kam raus, ne.
Moment, fünf, wie viele Wochen hat ein Jahr? 52 Wochen. Macht's gut, bis nächste Woche, haut rein.
52, wie lange gibt's das?
Ich darf hier noch ein bisschen rechnen.
Seit 2017.
Ansonsten haut rein, bis nächste Woche, bis drei.
Wir heben ab, macht's gut, ciao!